by lexingting hope i'm pronouncing well
who is professor at the department of
mathematics at stanford university
thanks yeah well thank you very much for
the introduction and i also would like
to thank katie and also simone for the
for the kind invitation and to give me
this opportunity to share some of my
recent results
so um so i changed the title of the talk
a little bit uh so
it's i'm gonna talk about some natural
breeding type of algorithm
for optimizing uh functionals over
probabilities okay
all right so here's the introduction so
the general task of this talk is to
try to consider the following problem
it's a minimization of a function over
probabilities and here a probability
distribution denoted by p
and the function noise denoted by ep
okay
and more specifically i'm going to talk
about
two cases so the first case is what i'll
call uh
the in the literature it's called
interacting free energy so in this case
the uh the the objective function the
functional consists of three parts the
first part is some sort of
divergence
with respect to a reference measurement
it doesn't need to be a clear divergence
as you will see it could be a general
form
and the second term is a linear term and
the last term is a quadratic term
and the reason why this is called
interactive free energy is because the
last term models interaction between
different particles which are described
by this probability distribution
so the second problem i'm going to
consider is is a slightly marginalized
form it's what i would just call the
mixed form and i'm not giving a precise
form here but as you will see later on
examples i'll show you the examples
but essentially this is consists of
three parts
so the first part is uh is a square of
the some kind of washer strength
distance
and the second part is kr divergence and
the last part is the square of the
mahalanobis
distance
so the goal is to for these two problems
uh we would like to design new
algorithms which
is first order algorithm but we want
them to be efficient and hopefully as
efficient as secondary algorithms
okay so let's consider the first problem
so again let me remind you that the
functional we are considering is so
called interactive free energy and it's
consisted of three parts the first part
is a divergence where the mu corresponds
to the reference measure
and the second part is a linear term
which is the single one and finally you
have a symmetric kernel w here and which
is this is gives you the interaction
now uh this this function appear earlier
in math biology and also in kinetic
theory so for example the certain
kiloseek models in methodology take this
form and also their examples in granular
flowing kinetics theory has been studied
which end of this framework
and more recently
this energy has also showed up in a mean
field modeling of the neural network
training now where about a couple of
years ago there are several groups
simultaneously propose using this to
understand a great uh gradient descent
as stock as the gradient center of your
network training
so um so the goal here is that uh we
want to find the minimum and if the
problems convex we want to find a global
minimum if it's not we'd be happy to
find the local minimum okay
and as i said we want the method to be
first order and also cheap to apply
now because this is a
optimization problem over probability
space so therefore the first thing of
methods that come in come to mind is
this famous mirror descent hydrocephalus
so here's the usual derivation of the
mirror the introduction the mirror
descent algorithm which essentially says
that you're going to perform an
iterative
algorithm like getting better and better
pks and at every step
would you oh
sorry every pk uh sorry at every step k
what you're going to do is you're going
to minimize this
objective function which serves as the
proxy of the true objective function ep
that you're trying to minimize over
and here the last term itself is an
important one and this is usually called
a regularizer and if you want to
optimize overprobability space and
typically the right regularizer to use
is the clear divergence okay
now
to get the mirror descent algorithm all
you need to do is just take group
derivative respect to p and if you take
derivative respect to p of this circuit
objective function and you get this
condition this is essentially the kkt
condition with a constant now you have
the constant on the right hand side
instead of zero because you
the the probability the mass has to be
preserved to be one so this is a
lagrange multiply
now simple calculus essentially tells
you that from here you can derive the
uh the probability distribution for the
k plus one step and this just involves
some exponential and multiplication
and finally we'll have to work out the
normalization uh term because
this term on the right hand side is not
necessarily always normalized so
therefore there's one extra step
so this mirror design algorithm has been
applied to
many problems in statistics machine
learning online learning specifically
and has a lot of success
now as applied mathematician we can ask
the from a numerical point of view is is
mirror descent accurate oh sorry it's
very descent efficient when mirror
descent is very efficient for example if
if a mirror designed with this ki
divergence as a regularizer is very
efficient if your objective function the
hashing of the objective function is
approximately equal to diagonal of over
p so this is the famous facial raw
metric
and for example if you're trying to
minimize the following quantity which
this is the famous
this is the usual quantity you see in
statistical mechanics where you have the
sum of the entropy term and also the
energy term and this is indeed the case
and the mirror descent with scale
divergence is extremely efficient
on the other hand if the uh if
the mirror descendant was killer
divergence as a recognizer is not
efficient if the hessian of the energy
function is far away from this
visual metric
now for example the case we consider has
three parts so if for example the first
part itself is not
chao divergence but some other kind of
divergence
for a general reference measurement then
um the hashing will not be
close to the visual metric
and more importantly our case because we
consider the interacting functional and
we have this w term so if w actually is
non-negligible that will also make the
hashing to be quite far away from the
artificial metric
so therefore the motivation of this talk
is to put for this problem is trying to
design new algorithm cheap new algorithm
which to accommodate this case
to understand the problem a little bit
better uh
i would like to share with you another
alternative another derivation of the
mirror descent algorithm which is much
more closer to the usual numerical
analysis perspective
so this is from natural gradient so what
essentially that you can start instead
of the discrete algorithm you can study
the continuous dynamics
just given by this it's a great descent
given by this
the metric which is which is the fischer
are metric
so this is the continuous dynamics and
it's usually written this way
now
the second step is to move the p to the
left hand side
so if you move to the p to the left-hand
side then you see that on the left-hand
side it's just a derivative of log p so
therefore you have the
equivalent equation which is given here
and
the third step is to perform the
explicit order discrimination for this
ode
and with the time step delta t which in
the machine learning community usually
written as eta so if you perform the
explicit order discretion and this is
the equation that you can get okay
and
if you write this out in terms by taking
exponential on both sides and this is
what you're going to get okay this is
exactly the merit design diversity
so in some sense you can view the mirror
descent algorithm as applying a natural
gradient
to the continuous gradient descent with
natural gradient metric which was the
measure given by fischer law
and uh performing explicit online
discrimination in this new variable log
p
okay
and finally you also have to work out
the normalization step but in this case
it's easy now here it becomes clear why
the
this mirror design algorithm works very
well for certain type of
functionals for example this one i give
on the previous slide the reason is that
if you calculate the hessian of this
objective function
it's exactly equal to the diagonal one
over p so therefore the fischer round is
actually equal to the hessian of this
objective function
and if you replace this over p with a
hessian and you see that this is nothing
but the newton dynamics right this is
the newton flow this is a continuous
flow of the
newton method because the newton method
has a second order convergence so
therefore you expect this to be quite
accurate
so one more thing i'd like to point out
that in this case in this special
example d e dp
is in fact equal to log p so therefore
this term in fact is log p
so this equation here is actually a
linear equation more or less a linear
equation this allows you to take and and
the ellipses constant is equal to one so
therefore this allows you to take very
large time steps you can take all the
way equal to one
okay
so with these perspectives we see that
uh well the the key success for the
efficiency of the mirror descent for
certain function is because
the diagonal metric that we use in the
natural gradient is actually very close
to the hessian of the objective function
so therefore the general plan that we're
going to follow with the following is
that we're going to start first by
choosing a diagonal metric
based on the objective function which
consists of these three parts right
and then we're going to introduce new
variables this row p oh sorry this is 5p
and this is corresponding to the log p
function we have in the previous slide
and we're going to write to the flow the
newton's law in terms of this 5p
variable
in the next step we're going to apply
explicit euler discretization to these
five p equations and finally we're going
to work out the normalization
so this is the
this is the viewpoint that we took
in this natural gradient kind of
framework going back to the mirror
descent language and what we're really
doing is that we're making the
regularizer to be depend on this
divergence and the reference measure and
also the interacting energy
so as far as i know and in most of the
voxel reference reviews of mirror design
algorithm so the reference uh the
regularizer is usually taken to be a
specific
fixed form for example either like a k
or divergence or a
quadratic barrier or sometimes like a
shadow entropy if you work with quantum
probabilities but then
but here the message
i want to share with you is that we have
some extra opportunity opportunity here
by making this regularizer to depend on
d and mu and the w we can actually make
the merit descent much more effective
so before i give you some examples i
will just let's just try to present
things in the discrete setting because
usually the formulas are look a little
bit easier to write down a little bit
easier to write down in the discrete
form
so we're going to assume that our space
it is neutralized by endpoints which is
where x1 to xn and p1 to pn correspond
to the probability mass at these
endpoints
and under this notation then the
discrete form of our
probability function of ep is going to
take this form okay
so just replacing the integral with the
sums
now what kind of diagonal metric are we
going to use okay in the case when w is
spd we propose to use a metric which is
given here
so
so the first term is corresponding to
the hessian of the the first term here
and the second term is linear in p so
therefore the hashing goes away it's
zero
and the third term is the hash is
actually equal to w right because it's a
psychological form
but
having the full w itself will actually
making the computation much more
expensive because eventually we have to
invert it so therefore what we decide to
do we just take the diagonal for example
we take the diagonal part of this uh
this matrix w and we are going to use
the diagonal part to to and combine with
the hashing from the divergence part to
do uh to be our metric
okay so when w is not spd then we can
simply just take the first part okay
so we have both algorithms work
algorithm what kind of in both cases but
in what follows i'm going to assume that
the w is spd and just talk about this
case first
okay i'm going to share with you a few
uh examples um so
so the first is one is a the chao
divergence case okay so this is either
case so um the the divergence still the
kr diverges with respect using some
respect to some measurement and the more
complicated part is that introduction of
this w this interacting energy
now as i said
in this case the hashing is going to be
the hessian of the divergence form which
is diagonal over p plus the diagonal of
my w matrix so it's written this one
so what we're going to do is uh next is
that i'm going to follow these four
steps i just described the general
recipe and see what this is going to
give in the in this special case
so the first step as i said we're going
to using this as our metric so therefore
this is our natural gradient aggregates
you see that difference compared to the
usual natural gradient algorithm over p
is that we have this w here which that
that's going to modify our algorithms
moving this term to the left-hand side
we will have this equation which is
involving this term log p plus wp so
this is our p are going to be a new
variable and you see that this also
appears on the right-hand side so
therefore in some sense this also is a
ode with lipschitz constant which is
roughly equal to one
so once we decide to use this as our new
independent variables we're going to
call it g and each of the component gi
is just equals to
log p up plus w i play okay notice that
this transformation is not fixed
for different coordinates to actually
depend on the w value at the coordinate
so therefore for every coordinate you're
using a different transformation
so
then you can rewrite this equation in
terms of the g variable and in the
vector form this is the one
and the next step is performing express
ola discrimination and that will give
you this formula
and um
and finally you have to work out the
randomization step so the normalization
step is actually not too difficult
even though i have this extra w
here the reason uh because of this w so
the inverse of this function log is not
exponential anymore this is some other
analytic function which so therefore you
want to figure out the normalization
constraint you have to solve in a linear
problem
but the good thing about here is that
this non-linear problem is actually more
or less monotone because of each of
these five functions the monotone so
therefore the deciding the c value can
be the constant
normalization constant can be done very
easily by doing some either binary
search or some kind of like
one-dimensional methods so but i'm not
going to go into the detail here okay i
just want to convince you that this is
actually the normalization step can be
worked out easily due to the model
monotonicity of my transformation
so for the sake of time i'm just going
to quickly give you one single simple
example so in this case uh we consider
the uh it's as a one-dimensional problem
periodic periodic domain zero one i
discretize with a thousand points and my
v is chosen to be a sine function and
this interacting energy is given by this
tri-diagonal matrix w
so i'm only going to use the idle to be
it's to to to deny the the diagonal
metric using the
natural gradient
prism
and this plot shows that everything
converges to 10 to the model 15 within
third iterations okay
so
so i'm going to
skip one of these examples just to save
some time so let me just go to this
example this example is an energy
distance so this is quite different from
decay of averages
so the high energy distance between to
properly measure p and mu is defined to
be the following form it's a square root
of p minus square root of mu squared
and up to a constant this is equal to
this term okay
so therefore the interactive energy in
our case in this hellinger case is given
by this
and you see that the first term is quite
different from from the
divergence and the last term is
interactive
now what is the hessian of this
function
because we need the hessians to design
our
our
metric
well if a simple calculation shows that
this is the hessian
coming from the hellinger divergence and
this is the uh
the diagonal part of hazard which comes
from w
all right following the general recipe
okay what we can do is that we're going
to use this metric that we derived on
the previous slide and study this other
a differential equation
okay
and
as i said one thing we can do is to move
this piece to the left hand side and try
to integrate that out and once you
integrate it out you see that this od
can be written
equivalently as an od of this new
variable okay
and i also want to point out that these
new variables appear on the right hand
side so therefore this is also like an
od with which is constantly equal to one
so that you can take large steps
so
by introducing this new variable g to be
this quantity uh we have this form
and
again the rest of the story the same
we're going to take the explicit ola
step and then we're going to do
lamination again the randomization is
easy to to do because of the these five
functions of monotone so uh
i just want to show you with this one
example and so in this case we're
working with this hydrogen averages
again with about a thousand points
um the the linear term v is chosen to be
zero
and the the the quadratic interaction
term is still going to be this
triangular matrix with alpha value on
the diagonal where alpha is equal to
about 100
okay
so the reference measure for the energy
distance is chosen to be a cubic
function so it has very small mass near
the origin but pretty big mass around
one
so the whole thing converges in about 15
to 20 steps and one thing i want to
point out that because we do this uh
forward because our the problem that we
get in this new variable is actually an
electric constant roughly equal to one
we can take huge time steps so delta t
is equal to one in this case
okay
all right so this is a summary of the
part one
so
the point the main point is that
we have to choose this metric uh
for the natural gradient so that
it it it
is close to the hessian of the my energy
function so in the language of the
mirror descent the regularizer should be
chosen to be dependent on the divergence
the reference measure and also w so this
will speed up the convergence
dramatically
now we one thing we didn't address is
the high dimensional case
so uh here i will give you examples 1d
and i also have 2d examples but in high
dimensional case usually the mirror
descent algorithm
have to discretize the domain so it's
usually another feasible algorithm in
high dimensional case for example in the
treatment neural network so something
has to be done up there and hopefully
the this this idea of designing the
metric based on the objective function
could be useful
okay
so i guess i started a little bit late
five minutes later i'll use the rest of
the 10 minutes to talk about the second
problem so in the second problem we're
trying to minimize a slightly more
generalized more general uh functional
so this function has three parts the
first part is
uh is is of the type like washington
distance uh from the base point square
the second part of this uh energy
functional is
still the cure divergence and finally
the last part is the
low base distance square so that can be
typical from a base point so it can be
written in this form and where the a
matrix we assume it should be zero
differential so for example you can
think about the a matrix to be
the ar operator to be for example a
power of the minus operation
now this problem itself is related to
optimal transport and also related to
many other
tools appeared in the machine learning
for example this last part is
essentially the kernel and this is
related to this maximum descriptors
now the goal is still the same we're
trying to find the first order method
for uh
find to to to minimize this problem and
we also want the cost to be low okay
now the lesson we learned from the first
part of the talk is that we need to
choose a metric which is close to the
hessian of my energy functional in order
for me for a natural gradient algorithm
to converge fast
so what would be the hessian of this ep
recall that my ep has three parts is
equal to e1 p plus e2 p plus e3 p right
and so therefore i need to study the
hessian for each of the individual
pieces
so for the rashes if if my e1 is of this
of the form of ashes like distance
squared so therefore it has shouldn't
roughly look like the following form
okay and the inverse of the hessian of
the of the session
is actually giving me this operator
which we're familiar with this is really
locally this is the local version of the
vacherstein uh greeting
metric
okay and the second term is uh is it
like the kr diver just so therefore we
know that hessian is like a diagonal of
a p this is a visual metric
and finally uh the mahalanobis distance
the square is is a very psychodic form
so therefore the hash is equal to a
so now in each of these three cases what
i claim is that we can derive the
hessian and we can compute the inverse
approximation by some very simple form
and then the inverse of this single form
can be appeared as a pre-conditioner for
my gradient descent right and they all
take very simple forms
for example this is just involved we
take the derivative this is diagonal
multiplication this is applying matrix
inverse
however when i apply add all three of
them together
and
the the sum of these three things is not
necessarily easy to invert
okay so that cause the main difficulty
so we want to find a method to
simultaneously diagonalize these three
pieces
so coming a bit from uh the the harmonic
analysis background i mean the only two
i know that can do that is a wavelet so
we're gonna also the rest part of this
talk is a little bit experimental so
we're gonna try to use a wavelet to see
where they can happen
okay so the algorithm we're going to do
in the following is that um
so record that
okay so the domain that we're going to
choose because of the wavelength so
domain we're going to choose it's going
to be a little bit restrictive it's just
going to be 0 1.
unit cube with a periodic boundary
condition
and
recall that the
the the functional is had the three
parts this
uh with the linear combination weights
alpha y phi 2 alpha 3. so therefore the
hessian of the whole thing is going to
be alpha one times this uh the the the
version like term alpha two times the
official route term and alpha three
times this the matrix a the operator a
now uh in the remaining of the talk what
i'm going to do is i'm gonna discretize
this periodic domain with a uniform grid
and i'm going to use d to stand for the
discrete differentiation operator and
use a w to stand for the discrete
wavelet transformation
now
we can take a look at what does the
hashing look like in the wavelet basis
this corresponding to multiply on the
left-hand side with w transpose with
right-hand side equals w right
once you multiply this and is this
exactly equal to this form okay in fact
this should be an equality here this
should not be the approximation okay so
the goal then is to see how whether we
can
try to whether the wavelet can
diagonalize
these three terms simultaneously
and it can in fact um
in a suitable condition it will as long
as the p itself is sufficiently bounded
away from zero meaning that there's no
place where the probability is very
close to zero and also the p itself is
roughly smooth then the wavelet will
diagonalize the whole thing in the sense
that if you take a look at this matrix
and and most of the important terms will
appear on the diagonal and the
the magnitude of the terms away from
diagonal will decay very rapidly to zero
okay so how do we construct all these
returns and in fact what i'm doing here
is just to write down what does the
diagonal of these three matrices look
like
so
in fact
as you see here each of them can be just
written in terms of linear operator
applied to my probability distribution
so for example the hessian of the first
term
in fact the diagonal part of the hash of
the first term is just given by this
vector which is 1 over h1p where h1 and
the matrix applied to my performance
distribution
and
the diagonal of the
hessian of the second part is also of a
similar form where this h2 matrix can be
also given out explicitly by each of the
entry of the h2 is given by this the
square of the wavelength transformation
now by and finally the the last piece is
the easiest because it's it does not
depend on p so therefore we can
pre-compute it and then we're just going
to use a diagonal to do and
to be its approximation
so putting all this together what we see
is that
this hession of the overall functional
can be approximated by a diagonal matrix
where the diagonal is the sum of these
three vectors
now
so this is our hash approximation that
showed up on the previous slides
so recall in the natural gradient
what we need is the inverse of the
metric because we need the inverse of
the metric to be applied to the gradient
vector in order to get
together right hand side of my dynamics
right
so therefore
in this case we can all we need to do is
by choosing the metric to be equal to
this diagonal approximation what we can
do is that the metric inverse is just
equal to the inverse of this object
but now we know that the wavelength
transformation is uh is a the orthogonal
transformation so therefore
so the the inverse of this operator all
we need to do is just invert the
diagonal part
so here's the two claims um
which
i'm not going to prove it but you can
find it in the paper essentially what it
says is that computing this h1 h2 matrix
can be efficiently it's really involves
only n log n is like a fast fourier
transform
and finally the applying this
this
the inverse of my metric
to
any gradient vector can also be done
using n log n steps again by taking
advantage of the fast food and fast will
be transferred
all right
so uh
i would like to briefly comment on the
time discrimination so um this is the
natural gradient algorithm
so when in the first part of the talk
we're just going to do a variable
transformation and then use explicit
online method to do this gradation
but here we cannot really do that so the
reason is because everything is done in
the wavelet domain and the constraint
that the probability mass has to be
greater than zero pose a very strong
condition for us
so therefore what we decided to do here
is just to use the line search method
with this mutual condition
and to enforce positivity
so essentially what it does is that
you're going to choose the right
direction
i evaluate the right-hand side of my
dynamics
and then you're gonna
start with the step size equal to one
if it's gonna fall off my probability
simplex or it's not gonna give me
sufficient to decrease then i'm gonna
backtrack a little bit until i get
a a time step which satisfy this
condition and then i move down to the
new step new location okay
now uh within the
two minutes what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna share with you some 1d and 2d
examples so here um the here um the
first part of the energy which what i'm
using here is really is a is h minus one
approximation of these uh uh
weichenstein distance squared
and the last term uh this low base term
is what i chose matrix a to be the minus
laplacian
so the reason i want to choose the minus
laplacian is i want to make sure that my
um
the global minimum of the minimum that
i'm trying to find itself is some
smoothness so therefore it makes sense
to use with it
so the three picture the full picture
shows here is that by combining these
energies for example let's just take a
look at the last one to save some time
so this is the energy function where i
have all three terms eisenstein fish
around and low base combine together
so if you're going to use vacherstein to
do as a pre-conditioner and it does not
really converge at all let's just stay
at a very high
error level
and if you use a fischer route it gets a
little bit better
if you have something because it gets
better if you have a major lopez it also
doesn't do very well
now but if you use a combined scheme
that i was described in the previous
slides you see that everything converges
with the internet iterations
so this shows you the benefit by
designing the precondition or the metric
by taking advantage of all three
functionals
and the wavelet we can have a much
better condition uh dynamics when
compared to the unconditioned or poorly
conditioned dynamics okay
so this is the 2d example we see the
same picture here and in this case the
fischer actually does not do
bad it's actually fairly decent
but but you see that the combined
dynamics that we designed is actually
much faster it converts in 25 iterations
to 10 to the minus total okay
so the take-home message is that in this
case we we use a wavelet and we try to
diagonalize the the combined hessian
approximately the combination matrix and
then use this as a preconditional for uh
to obtain our
natural gradient algorithms
so a lot of question remains the willvit
has a restriction so for example i can
only apply to
rectangular domains how do we work with
the general domains
designing wavelet for that is not easy
and so this is an interesting question
and also in this part of the second for
second problem and because i want to use
a wavelet i require my probability not
too close to zero and also
i require my px to have a certain
regularity so
this is the condition which i don't know
how to remove and
if if p is not regular then we'll have
to probably have to design other kind of
tools to replace a wavelet
finally the same question is that how
about high dimensional case and here i
work with only 1d 2d and 3d but in high
dimensional case certainly you cannot
discretize whole space so therefore
it's a it's it's a much more difficult
question
so finally i'd like to thank you for
your attention and these are the
references uh this is a reference for
the first part of the talk this
reference for the second part of talk
so i think about a couple of days ago
leewa also gave a talk which is related
to the first part of the talk and so
this is their paper here so finally
thank you very much for your attention
and i'm happy to take questions if
there's any questions thank you
questions for beginning
i actually have one just to be sure i
understood like so um on your plus you
were like the last plots uh you are
comparing the
so yeah the loss and
for each iteration but your iteration
of the scheme you propose is more
expensive due to this wavelength
decomposition rate
no it's not more expensive it's a it's
it's analog gain
so that's what these two claims you want
to have a method which is almost like a
linear method
so
so
so so for example if you uh right so
you're absolutely right i mean it's
slightly more expensive
because for example if you want to do
fish around you just need a diagonal
multiplication if you want to do a
fashion style you need to take the
gradient diagonal multiplication and do
another kind of adjoint of the gradient
here is a little bit more expensive it's
a n log n steps so it's
we have to consider log n factors so
yeah so in that sense you're right so
maybe in terms of running time the per
iteration our method will be slightly
more expensive yes okay thanks
thank you that's a good point and also a
very naive question related to the first
part of the talk uh
like this renormalization step
yeah is it easier because you you modify
the metric or
oh and then it's yeah it's it's fairly
easy because it's it's essentially it's
uh you need to that the normalization
step has to be some kind of a non-linear
um like a root finding anyway because
even you think about it in the
exponential case uh we we never really
think about taking the exponential to be
a root finding but it is a nonlinear
function so essentially any time you
take the log or the exponential it's
kind of like group finding so here is in
some sense another root finding uh it's
what i claim here and what i showed here
is that
because the function itself
the function here
for example this one itself is a
monotone function in c so therefore um
finding the root is very easy and uh in
fact i mean so you can you can show that
the c will always guarantee be within
this interval so therefore the simplest
method which has to be bisection you're
starting from the middle point of this
interval and you start to search letter
right until you find the c
and there's only one single this
normalization step only need to be done
once right it's it's independent of how
many uh coordinates you have your
probability distribution
okay thank you
questions
if not uh thank you very much
for the talk
okay thanks a lot
we are back at